The three US states with the best healthcare system
No. 3 Minnesota.
With approximately 94%
of its population covered by health insurance,
Minnesota stands out for its
robust healthcare infrastructure and initiatives.
The state consistently ranks high in health outcomes
and access to care
due to its extensive network of healthcare providers
and emphasis on preventive services.
No.2 Hawaii
this island paradise
boasts an impressively low uninsured rate of around 4%,
primarily due to
the state's employer based health insurance system.
Hawaii's unique Prepaid Healthcare Act
mandates that employers provide health insurance to
employees working over 20 hours per week,
ensuring widespread coverage.
Before revealing the number one,
remember to subscribe and like the video.
No. 1 Massachusetts
known for its top notch healthcare system,
boasting one of the highest
rates of insured residents in the nation
at around 97%.
The state's Innovative Healthcare Reform,
including the landmark 2006 health insurance mandate,
drastically reduced the uninsured rate
and increased access to care.
And you, do you live in one of these states
and do you agree to this?
Let me know in the comments.